- Hark, there she be.
(dramatic threatening music plays)
- Follow me.
Your griffin queen.
Away from this fortress
and back to the kingdom of Eldervale.
- But what about the king?
(loud growls and scrapes)
- The king is dead.
- I case you haven't noticed, I'm weird.
I'm a weirdo.
I don't fit in.
I don't wanna fit in.
Have you ever seen me
without this stupid hat on?
That's weird.
(chanting)
(alarm beeps)
(babies gurgle)
(high chord plays)
(dog growls)
(loud whooshing)
(chord plays)
(growling and loud punching)
- This is a message for the coward
calling himself the Black Hood.
You think you can attack
us from the shadows,
but Riverdale is a lot stronger than you.
And we're not afraid.
You see, there's only one of you,
but we are legion.
We're called the Red Circle.
And we're coming for you.
(dramatic music plays)
(whoosh and arrow vibrates)
- I suggest you run whilst you still can.
I only miss when I mean to.
(dramatic music plays loudly)
(arrow whooshes)
♪ Children waiting for
the day, they feel good ♪
♪ Happy birthday, happy birthday ♪
♪ And I feel the way
that every child should ♪
♪ Sit and listen, sit and listen ♪
(Mad World plays)
♪ And I find it kinda funny, ♪
♪ I find it kinda sad ♪
♪ The dreams in which I'm dying ♪
♪ Are the best I've ever had ♪
♪ I find it hard to tell you, ♪
♪ I find it hard to take ♪
♪ When people run in
circles it's a very very ♪
♪ Mad world ♪
- If we weren't here we'd be
in high school, joining clubs
trying out for sports.
- Not me.
I dropped out in the fourth grade,
to run drugs, to support my nanna.
- That means you haven't know
the triumphs and defeats,
the epic highs and lows
of high school football.
But you will.
(rock music plays)
♪ The warden threw a party
at the county jail. ♪
♪ The prison band was there
and they began to wail. ♪
♪ The bank was jumpin' and
the joint began to swing. ♪
♪ You should've heard those
knocked out jailbirds sing. ♪
♪ Let's rock ♪
♪ Everybody, let's rock. ♪
♪ Everybody in the whole cell block ♪
♪ Was dancin' to the jailhouse rock. ♪
(mournful singing)
(sighs)
(gentle music plays)
- Hello Archie
My name is Monica Posh.
I'm with Riverdale's chapter
of the innocence project,
and I'll be working to help
get you out of this place.
(piano plays softly)
(sexy pop music plays)
- So, to settle this
matter once and for all,
maestro?
- Okay, ah sure--
♪ That's not my name ♪
Ah, Cheryl.
♪I hear that word, sounding so sweet, ♪
♪ Thousands of voices forever repeating. ♪
♪ Carrie Carrie, Carrie. ♪
(upbeat dance music plays)